yo yo hello
check check
what's up fool podcast and again locos
podcast today we got Mike rollers right
here man the executive CEO originator of
get locals bro started off at other
[ __ ] local axis over art parking in
the Queen's right Bronx the Bronx yet
look Y so consults adopted right
how many per company rumba recovery room
barbers right right that was covered
Aruba for the Bronx which got me comedy
beacon company because the later I was
also on local Isis no cavalry Bacardi
wasn't gonna miss you but um that's
right comedy Picanto came out before
comedy kid look who was happy or
afterwards before before but it never
made it to the West Coast ha that show
no I did cover EP country strictly it
was an East Coast thing because I want
to give all the East Coast comedians but
the natural rights poacher but didn't
come out I don't want a Westco the show
right before they did yeah we would have
a musical guest at the end and all that
stuff I don't remember then after that
ok local scared cuz after you got get
locals after happy that's when the
production went up and started looking
pro yeah that's they true all those
episodes out well what happened bro it
was horrible it wasn't like a Arturo
Flacco Dennis I got comedy picante
old-school style then next thing I know
I'm watching right it is happy very
happy yeah so I get a call made you know
that me after the first six episodes the
president of galleries young say missin
I apologize we made a mistake we want to
bring you back when you take all
episodes we're gonna take all those
episodes double bull and that's where
locals was created man double triple
those ratings winner I don't even know
we did I was out I was on that show bro
company get locals happy you know
and now we taped it I don't know where
we taped a pro but I just know there was
no audience there was no audience a
[ __ ] the matter if I have more bags
than the carbons bro the producers of
no-shows
I think spent like a year in jail for I
don't know what what the you know
something you know where you finagle
money what does they call it something
like that I didn't get I know that and I
know that I didn't get no money the kind
of money or the comedian comical
comedian bro would wind up to like I
don't know who was in charge and they
were in there bro that they were
professional bra store asking for to see
that was a problem then I would think it
like whatever these fools ask for five
g's how much do they lit a whole store
what I heard you know I'm the great
bankers I was just happy to be there but
it was me it's a Baptist at Tina's chill
every burger Bert um like your dress
come on Cooper Discoverer was with
Louisville red or somebody else but I
was all together bro I don't know bro
and felt like we were held hostage
I don't do with that
nothing you're all in the East Coast New
York I was in the you hosted an episode
of Kellogg yeah but I was a law we
should talk to one new look too happy
and corporate I'm not dressing happy
happy happy was the whole he had nothing
to do with the price no man I was the
host that he did his thing
the people who hold he was a host and
organized you know I mean you get twenty
I'm gonna give him a tea you get ninety
you known all over saw her there's some
community the finagle fight geez bro I
bombed already she asked for five g's
[Laughter]
speechless he said does let me give
5,000
she said it right at a does bro oh geez
Ernie G energy we did cover TK local
comedy K locals they Santonio the
production value was low bro like calm
she's mad it was like huh I don't know
who the audience if I don't have it
audience is hard they grab your mouth
side hey come on in even though what
happened is very simple bit let's say
you were giving I don't know you give it
a 10 I'm gonna spend a dowsing to put
19,000 in my pocket nothing went to the
production nothing what it was how much
can i the producers made that's why I
was horrible that's why when I did my
thing man it was all in the production
how did you or was it you who did the
deal with Network yes so how did you
convince them to put an english-speaking
show on a Spanish Network that's like
them that hasn't happened since so that
I know of right not just stand up but
any sort of English it's crazy because I
was doing one of my shows that
Caroline's comedy club in New York and
at the time got a vision wanted to get
innovative with being the first English
speaking testing it out program they
realized there were bilingual people
watching yes they could bring over a new
crowd yes yes yeah well the the assisted
a personal assistant of the president of
Gallaudet happen to be in the audience
that day he said United to show us funny
you gotta go check it out so then the
next show we had at Caroline's the
president came down checked it out he
wanted to see me in the office the
following week and you said only a Bobby
bites comes to you know Bobby bites came
along because I was doing the show what
was it when did they can local thing
right so during the time of doing it
locals you know they have these your
intern musicians and stars they do these
right what do they do when they produce
all the shows we call those warm-ups no
no when they when they they put out all
the shows and they invite people I shall
get me the programming for the next
season all up France yeah you were two
up France for that show no no no no the
president actually goes would you mind
doing an upfront like promo for me like
eight minute real about gala vision and
up France for people who don't know are
like a corporate showcase of all the
shows coming out that fall so the
advertisers can go oh I want to put my
ads on this show I'm already out in
Miami I'll do it
so we did that and it was very
successful and he called me goes you
know I didn't realize you were very good
hosts in the web I guess I did so the
upfront video stuff so he goes I want
you to do a show a video show for me but
I want you to make it funny and that's
where video mix came in yeah so we
created a video mix from the beginning I
went and I picked up Bobby bytes costume
and went to a store and it's the tease
everything anyway we did video mix and
that was like for two years like 52
episodes and that's where I want my Emmy
Award for that show Bobby bites
wonderfully so I got lucky I mean you
know I so I hacked your locals going I
had video of it's going radio mix opened
up and then key locals came afterwards
on top but a world mom oh no
everything's rolling everything was good
and then we did the tour after that you
know
but um it was crazy bro like oh oh well
now when you kick my head to the west
coast did you do our start off k local
in the East Coast first right so I
remember I went over there yeah me
myself Reuben Quintana just the other
day Frank Manzano that's right and a
bunch of other people we started at the
East Coast and Franchi some days your
bro
that's right but it was booked half of
the people bro that's right and that's
what we did like I think maybe like 6m
it was the comic strip yeah the comic
strip and I remember the shout out to
the owner he passed away
yeah and the ratings were OK yeah and I
remember brew like I was nervous bro
hosting over there and I were wearing
this horrible black suit I bought a
[ __ ] target bra for 200 bucks
no let's enjoy the bus it was bad and a
lot of turn to just joins legitimate
she's here right now we're talking about
kid lock was I remember this show that
we were on back in the day oh yeah
angler show on gallery see yeah so you
say better the comic strip you were in a
black suit Oh wear the black suit is
still out there man and now I remember
man I love our first time in New York
actually too and I hosted I don't even
know what could be either brought up I
don't remember
I'm here now that was that we tear away
which was the best of it
then I'm [ __ ] out Roger Park came
everywhere without with an ode an ICM
shirt bro ICM hat yeah yeah and you're
gonna watch myself okay and then he goes
up hey man we're gonna change house
we're to put up DJ who the [ __ ] j-jim a
good techno take your ovaries so he
[ __ ] hosted that [ __ ] bro it yeah he
does like 40 minutes of rug I don't know
but I broke and they start going at
there's a lot of them indicate that all
right I don't see socks and then dude he
did a great job but then he brought up
what's his name Bob all right all right
check it out check it out angel Salazar
bro all right so he just a lizard does
[ __ ] [ __ ] bro it's a long as beard
dude he's brought up all these props
he has like so I don't know what the
code would you ask questions but you
have a ringer or somebody that working
with you it in the show already a plan a
plan yeah yeah yeah so I didn't know
that he he had a plan already so he
didn't know this time of the movie was
hot
The Bodyguard with what's your name
Whitney Houston a bodyguard bit and now
he's dressed up like Whitney Houston bro
and the song is played and I really goes
it dressed like a chick he's goes I
wanna draw somebody from the stage
somebody on the audience to help me out
right now for the nice bed this is a
girl bra [ __ ] up with me baby over and
over and he's supposed to help me out
then he goes now you [ __ ] okay then he
breaks Kara do not you [ __ ]
then he grabs this big-ass dude over
here you sir it is like this big old
Mountain hillbilly foo then he grabs in
your son and son like a baby like a butt
like it's his body gonna walk away dog
so he brought nobody went over these
bits was watch appalled can I just smell
some rumors can local rumors oh yeah all
right what are those first what is
everybody's always asking what happened
to get locals here to here bro
I heard I heard that microbrews went to
the studios and ask for too much money
in the said [ __ ] you killed it yeah what
did you hear
I heard the same thing bro mmm foul and
then I heard what else I hear bro let it
out don't know but I heard somebody
saying I was that some girl was gonna
hear that some lady I don't know
I heard that the show was also like
killing uh Kenny the the spending
ratings for the next hour next hour two
hours so people watch your local so much
that you could you were getting
Armenians from Glendale watching the
show now and crossing over Asia they cut
it off right before it really crossed
over because Bobby Lee always give props
to the show hey bro what I did a premium
blend also on [ __ ] Damon Wayans with a
hose bro you got one I've seen this guy
on shows like ke locos he basically and
I heard that they just took the show out
because they just have no place to put
it and also they want to pay no more no
no kind of a very simple man ya know cuz
exactly we were doing really good in the
ratings we will be the wrestling soap
operas soccer soccer traditional
traditional Spanish shows ke moko's was
kicking their ass on number one so I get
a call the president decides he wants to
cancel the show because all the we shown
is traditionally a spanish-speaking
network and they felt English didn't
belong there
and I was like seriously and we had
another meeting and we cited that after
all those episodes they just decided
that after all those exactly so he said
yeah and that people were calling again
saying hey what are you doing with
spanish-speaking programming this is a
Latino station what why they speak in
English on Univision so the way Latinos
kind of won the whole thing
- why those brown Latinos speaking
English so T so I bought him like emails
and different stuff saying like look at
only this whoa what do you mean you're
gonna cancel it right he goes we need to
just have Spanish can you do the show
and somatic you said it
so he said show's canceled as simple as
that okay well how about the other 26
episodes I got to do he goes you're
gonna get paid don't worry about it but
you're not doing the shows I said how
about video makes you're gonna get paid
so I got paid for doing nothing
basically so anyway that's the reason
vocals went off the air what do you
beast you decided no more
english-speaking programming and to this
day almost 20 years later 20 they don't
even do in
faking commercials so that's why Kay
what goes with castle good you got my
chromatid here where people get locals
just regular down just one more room I
got it dispel because this is what I
hear I got eaters did I hear this so do
we talk about about Carlos Australasia
yeah the comic Oscar story like oh Lost
Children yeah he missed
I saw that podcast you did with you bad
what do you say you well basically you
know he punched me I don't know what it
was but like and thunder cuz I asked the
brother little hey bro how are you miss
listen Carlos if you're listening well
we're all due respect bro I know you
were born-again Christians you carry the
Bible before you go on stage you say a
prayer so I'm gonna speak the truth and
hopefully you agree with me bro but you
walked into chemicals that afternoon we
were taping pissed off because I had
replaced you as the host of that show
because you didn't get back to me in
time so I had to replace you so you
walked in through the door with some
bodyguard is some some muscle dude who
stood on this side and he wrote right up
to my face you probably me me me I said
bro I said listen why don't you come
back tomorrow you know we'll have lunch
we'll talk about it we're gonna settle
this right now
then he says let's go outside come on
man so he starts walking one step two
step third step he turns around and
swings at me right and he holds me by
the shirt whoa
so I get the move right arica chokehold
I don't know I guess it's probably that
right so the whole idea was grab a PAPR
grab you by the shirt pull you in and
punch you the only problem is right you
up Miami always used to wear those looks
right I have a snap on show Bobby bites
never goes undetected
so as he graduated broke group as he
grabs my shirt I go be in the buttons go
snap snap snap snap snap and I start
falling back and he's holding the shirt
and he misses on you know next day he's
holding this shirt and his punch miss so
he's like this down so I got a clear
shot and right down the middle when I
went boom punched him right in his
[ __ ] face bro laughs and he went down
he went down and I jumped on him with
the Yankees and I put my right here I
had him right there oh no you [ __ ]
I told you come tomorrow we'll have
lunch but you don't want to listen to
that [ __ ] right up about Tina squat put
up Sione
at that time at that time his afraid he
bought chops me from behind graslie by
the neck who was this threesome he pulls
me off and says don't hit him don't hit
him bro whatever you do don't hit him
he's the man of the Bible as he's
pulling me off right cause his on the
floor and he starts kicking me he starts
kicking got a kick now well you got me
in a choke hold the [ __ ] out of here
anyway he doesn't go walking out he go
stumbling out as Jeff Garcia he was
pulling up in the same dock and Jeff
Garcia says he goes I saw him walk out
his face was all red and submit what
that will happen in the Puerto Rican
hurricane dog Mike Robles dog Carlos
that's the truth well I only say it
because the truth has to be told it's
like 20 years ago
I'm just asking you guys haven't on a
show together in 20 years I made a
documentary about the you know my host
condition yeah I don't know how long
I'll be around so let's get back to that
people never gentlemen this this Friday
tomorrow we're gonna have nothing to
have like a live charity for you right
so it better fit for me how many I like
better
you know I got [ __ ] cancer
okay I want to hear the story from me
whoever wrong so I'm speaking the
Gabriel aggressive though I love Gabriel
Iglesias
I don't like fluffy so what do you mean
well of course you know started the
whole thing for him
you don't say they started the whole
thing like I saw him on a podcast ask
him like hey whatever to kill okay look
at this bro I created him locals role I
created it I got the talent
I created the tour the tour not the show
but the tour the trainer was [ __ ] it
made him a superstar
bro that's what he knows and I know he's
made home was superstar and he would get
pissed off when comics go oh you know
what if it wasn't for micro but she
won't be where you're at he hate it when
he heard that [ __ ] he had it was
the truth is the truth it was that so I
you know III I put him on and I put its
rate I made him that superstar who he
was at the time now I'm let's say he
wonder where to start today I'm just
saying I put him on the fast track I was
a launching pad I put him in the fast
track you know so today you know like
guaro 911 bro yeah yeah so you know I
have my little benefit coming up and so
on Philippe it was nice enough to make a
generous donation I would have been
there the benefit brooch a little cherry
not to be there I don't know why so
that's one say Gabriel I don't know what
I did to you I know I did nothing all I
did was help you maybe he's getting
third-hand information about shitty hood
which is not true but I got no love for
you Gabriel this fluffy guy I don't like
I'm just saying right I got number four
the brother man but for the fact that
what I'm going through right now
I don't care what is beef is I would
expect him to reach out you know
anything hope you feel better he was a
visionary here what's going on but
nothing's my book bro give them Ricky
Jerret bro hey man I thought it killed
you with my breath man I got out what I
did it to get out and I appreciate you
bro for letting me do it because thank
you for this would be forever out there
when everybody got a microbus story just
check out this podcast we're gonna get
you back bro
it's in the end of the micro Blair's
interview when it man Turner who is the
late Rafi Mays wife she wrote chef Rafi
mains wife she was seeing a documentary
that she's pushing I'm based documentary
movie um so it's a documentary but if
you help backers oh can I just say quick
rough email there for time I met him
rough eBay yeah was that the hotel right
no the Laugh Factory this is what we're
doing kill locals right and he comes out
there he goes hey man let me do Kahlo
cause I'm a lot funnier than that other
fat guy so funny that you say that cuz
like to hear like a fat guy hating on a
fat guy is the same thing as sitting
here here like Mexican comics hating on
other Mexican chicks hating on [ __ ]
nobody has time for this like we need to
do other things and like yeah George
Perez hitting on the wall G side big
Eddie hitting on that guy with a bzzt so
about this shift gears here to talk
about your documentary
dude it's doing it's been crazy we we
premiered in Nashville won best of the
fest when we premiered at dock LA and
won best dock at all and dock a layout
of all the documentaries and I just did
an E news segment on Friday so national
press out of a dock that doesn't have we
don't distribution yet I'm still
figuring out where it's gonna air so
it's a very impactful story I was
wondering cuz like I was thinking about
Netflix cuz Netflix has up their
standards as far as like cameras being
used and all that stuff and I wonder I'm
sad because this this uses a lot of real
footage and old video footage and stuff
and real phone videos and photos and
stuff but like I don't know that I mean
I feel like they would be losing out by
not selecting something like this and I
don't know in forward everyone's getting
you know like these crazy TVs yeah but
documentary is different you can't have
a documentary that spans the course of
20 years having a lot of jannat so I
think that that's one of those areas I
hope that it still gets the attention
even though like you know some of the
footage is not you know it's it's not
like did you get a chance to watch it Oh
yeah I loved it and and it's it's uh I
mean it's a lot of what you said during
your last visit here you know but in
video and pictures you know and and it's
I mean it's all right there everything
that you were talking about the last few
years and you know yeah little snippet
to see how much a dick man cow is oh you
watch okay so you can't sleep you
haven't had a chance to you know I've
been a man called before though oh my
god funny you bring that up though yeah
ty Rivera and Anna Dillon Garcia
one-time man he was totally rude to them
I II didn't really didn't even get a
chance to promote her so yeah he didn't
give me that day he didn't give me a
chance to promote but not only that he's
rude he's like he's like he's deceased
he stated that character and he don't
get off of it especially when he goes
down on Obama train
he'll just forget about the guests oh
yeah well I mean he looks really bad at
the end no I mean he doesn't personally
look bad but in the film it's not
intentional I'm not sure I didn't even
edit the film so that's a really
important thing to note about this movie
because I started the project I hired
can actually Ralphie and I started it
together and then he says this was the
wife's idea yes it was my idea it was my
idea to hire a cat was my idea but but
Ralphie always wanted to do more reality
and I was against doing reality TV so
this was you know there was all right
last comic and Celebrity Fit Club so we
literally we had people approach us
every six months or so to do some form
of reality and I always turned down
because we did a pilot for vh1 which
that footage is also in this film years
ago and I hated the experience so much
so I didn't ever want to do it was
straight up reality but this was
different because we hired a friend of
ours and she went on the road with him
for nine months and it just was not the
story I'd hoped to capture I mean we had
hoped it was going to be a weight loss
journey which it's obviously not we were
now his second gastric bypass so he'd
had to bastard surgeries and I was
against him having any more gastric so I
was like you know I would be about you
I don't think you could qualify blow it
is that you need one huh you want the
sleeve you know the thing is some
gastric sleeve the thing about it
tightens your stomach I don't know just
digging me out a staple never stop you
know cakes do you think when you watch
the film really the message isn't isn't
even diet and exercise it's mental
health oh yeah well that guy says it to
the trainer trainer no no the other guy
and the chubby the other chubby oh yes
he says magus mike mangas Mickey
maximize I forget his name's Teddy okay
yeah yeah that one he said he makes a
comment and says why is he getting
another one doesn't matter how many you
get the problem is up here because he
did any and Ralphie proof that he ate
through two surgeries so this is before
the third one yeah and I was an event
center
I was against him having gastric anymore
gastric surgeries but I was also I mean
I before we started filming I I'd sit
down with him and I said look I think
you're gonna die like you have to do
something and if you can't do it on your
own like at least if we did the surgery
it's gonna take a couple hundred pounds
off you at least for now we'll extend
your life but I did not agree with that
as being an option and it turned out he
couldn't he could have gotten it but it
wouldn't have been covered by insurance
cuz even the insurance companies were
like not gonna work dude and and so the
journey began I mean he he had no
intention of really losing the weigh-in
in hindsight but there was so much more
wrong with him it's almost like the
process I mean I I feel like watching
that I feel like Ralphie battled food in
his mind every second of the day he
battled whatever it's amazing yeah right
later on yeah a good addict I think
we'll switch addictions over there time
right so like no matter what it is you
you need unless you fix the problem
that's causing the need to fill that
void you're gonna find something to fill
the void and so in his case food was a
was you know I was joke you can't quit
food cold turkey because it's delicious
so he's always around that substance
yeah you can't block a walk that's clean
you can't get away from it right like
you're always gonna be be around food
and then but he at the I don't know if
you could tell and in the in the subtext
but he was very much to be using
prescription pain pills at the end of
his life and you know finance everything
it just became a spiral I don't know if
I did I mention at our wedding that I
mentioned how we went that we noticed
Ralphie's face during the wedding no
like I didn't know I don't know if I
mentioned it on the last podcast but
during the war toward the end of the
wedding you know yeah April was just
bouncing off the walls right and so
happy and I bounced with her and we
danced for a long time and she but then
and Ralphie was dancing for a little bit
but then things changed I don't know if
he took something during the course of
the evening or what but he looked like
he was a zombie at one point later on in
the night and we talked about it that
night we mentioned it to each other on
our wedding night like concerned about
I'm worried about Ralphie like you know
his face was just like he just was like
out of it just staring almost like a
zombie like yeah it was sad and you know
so there were other things going on but
yeah I mean it became a really big issue
for us I mean like we had a really
difficult dismount because after the
film stopped shooting you know he that
ended pretty much there was a few more
opportunities or acount got to film him
and myself but the filming pretty much
stopped with him filing for divorce and
that was really really hard because he
was angry he filed and then proceeded to
just be so angry with me which i think
is also in line with being a really sick
addict because he needed somebody to
blame like if you took responsibility
for his actions and he would have had to
have changed and so there was no
responsibility there and it just all
became like this horrible thing and and
because of that look you saw at his
wedding he could be around his children
anytime he wanted but not alone because
he could pass out like he'd just fall
asleep and they were little and that was
a big point cuz I know I'm pointing out
his problems I'm saying you can't be
alone with your kids you can be with
them and what well I don't have a
problem I can't be alone so everybody
can see you have a problem but yeah it's
really sad a backlash from the
documentary
you've got some haters in the comedy I
love that you asked about the haters Oh
somebody asked if I have here sort of
their point I asked if you had backlash
on the dot yes but the thing is the
people that are hating haven't seen it
yet yeah so they're just hating based on
what they perceive is the story from
their perspective right yeah so I mean I
don't and I don't know what they see but
I do get like the ik a like I get
messages online and I just like if
they're worth answering I'll write them
back and say you know like if this is
something that you need to learn more
about and the movies coming out or I'll
send them a link to an article or I'll
just delete them because it doesn't do
me any good but yeah some of the comics
like I hate to even mention people's
names because I feel like you give them
protein them promote them because
whenever they say my name more fans find
me like they'll go look at my youtube
because they're angry about something
and then they'll be like the end this
[ __ ] is funny like good say my name I
don't care if you say it out of anger or
whatever but they don't know the real
story so like when you know Joey was
been really hard to me and I was never
anything but nice to that guy ever
I don't know Joe Athena's always been
nice yeah he's he's been really verb
vocally mean and I'm like dude I've
never been anything but nice to that guy
so I think I mean does that help him or
just video more probably I don't know I
mean I look at I have my own stories
that stemmed back to 20 years with that
guy that you know but like I don't I
don't want to have a beef with anybody
it doesn't do anyone any good but the
reality is you can listen to his podcast
he can say horrible things about me and
then you can look at the context of it
hey Ralphie was doing drugs with him
five months before he died on his
podcast so you know their relationship
wasn't grounded in a healthy one and
like what if you really love Ralphie you
really want to see the best thing for
him then you want to see the best first
children so even if you dislike me like
why come after me in a professional way
you're only hurting his kids and that
tells me that you don't care about
Ralphie that's it
it's a nutshell
a lot of people I know you know Joey
knows you guys more than some of the
other people who want to talk [ __ ] or
whatever but I think that these people
just come up with their own narrative
their own narrative and but that was the
interesting thing about the documentary
is that it's all right there everything
is right there for you to see the whole
the whole breakdown of your relationship
the whole breakdown of him on on tour I
mean people say that I'm like a
money-grubbing [ __ ] because they see
that I'm thin and that Rafi was heavy
and how could she have possibly been
with this man he's she was clearly a
gold digger and then but you guys have
known me like I was with Ralphie for
more years in a row and then before it
yeah and and there was nothing promising
about his career back that I mean was
funny but they wouldn't put him on TV
like he had to really Jay Mohr made that
big difference for him so yeah I mean
people who don't know the story and
here's the real we've all done that
right we've all looked at somebody and
gone there's no way that that's legit
like he's really old she must want his
money and sure people think I'm a gold
digger every time you post the picture
well especially with my blonde hair hey
there you know he'd post a picture in
social media people thought it then they
don't know the story I don't know but
he's after my pesos does that mean that
just because somebody has money and they
aren't like a physical standard that
they can't find love to without the
person absolutely being after their
finance I mean I you know it makes it
really hard for anyone to have a
relationship but you just have to ignore
that and know that that those people are
probably miserable in their own rights I
mean there was one female comedian they
came after me so hard like during the
indiegogo said that she didn't like me
and I I picked up the phone I have her a
number of my phone I think she's been to
my house for our barbecues and I picked
I just call her and I'm like hey if you
have a problem let's talk I'm certain
I'm gonna see you at some point and of
course she doesn't call me back because
it's easy to troll behind a computer and
she's obviously a miserable human being
because what like again you care about
ralfie then why are you why are you
jacking with me like I I'm taking care
of his children and you know it's just
and then also I never did anything to
her but be nice to so like that's her
problem that's his problem
I'm my side of the street I just work
really hard and I
the film is good the film shows the
story and that's another reason why for
a long time I stayed quiet like TMZ miss
published stuff about Rafi and I like
that he that I had been the one to file
that wasn't true all these things were
said that were not true but I knew
eventually with this film I I would get
my opportunity to speak up and so much
of it is from Ralphie's mouth oh my god
it's all right I mean so much of how he
feels about you and so much about how
you were instrumental in his career it's
all him he wanted this film to people
are another comment we get is oh people
saying Oh Rafi didn't want this and the
twins are really like mal and like those
guys oh they like they love to talk [ __ ]
but they the reality is is that hmm
they miss eating for free on my dime
yeah yes that's but they they love to
talk stuff but the twins brought an
impression of but like I I mean they
they they're he missed the greatest
opportunity Chad did because he was in
the film he had a big part in there and
because cat kept reaching out to him to
talk to him about it and he kept blowing
her off and then he went around talking
a lot of stuff it's like so you have an
opportunity to be in a film where you're
gonna be seen by probably millions of
people and really help your career but
you're too big you can't get out of your
own way and and and and tell the truth
tell the true story yeah Ralphie it was
really sick yeah you had your hand in
his pocket whatever it is tell the truth
is just a lot better than what you know
because Ralphie says in the beginning to
or the footage that's used in the
beginning that I'm a flawed individual
and you know I want to show all the good
and the bad in this documentary and you
tell my story be honest good or bad yeah
and Ralphie never really hid from
anything I mean like he was a pretty
open honest person about a lot well a
lot of things that were public there are
a lot of things that weren't so honest
and again an addict yeah hides a lot of
stuff yeah so I mean they were hiding
soda there was like a soda cartel that's
all I was the coke skiing when my folks
killed me like the because you you you
kind of set it up where you say
came two years ago and said I don't want
to be fat anymore please help me yeah
and that put you in a tough position
because now you're like the policeman
you know now you're like this watchdog
and that becomes your job because you
want to help him reach his goal you love
him so much you want him to reach that
but you're now it changes your
relationship I think and then and now
you guys are just obsessing about cokes
did he have a coke or not and it's just
like wow like it came down to that like
that's a fighting point Co cause I'm a
major issue between us be Cola one time
ice so here's how coke works when you
have gastric bypass it eats your
intestinal wow I didn't yeah because you
don't have the stomach to digest that so
my argument to try and keep him off of
soda was not just oh I don't want you
drinking soda I wasn't just based on
that I and to be honest with you like
he's a grown-ass man like if he's gonna
drink soda he's gonna do it
I can't stop that and but I'd all these
people sneaking around behind my back
making sure he gets soda I watched him
one New Year's Eve in just nine cans of
coke at The Improv in Florida I think
was nine so does in be in between you
know the New Year shows there's usual be
on stage bro with a picture bro it's a
picture of a picture of Diet Coke and a
straw no that's talking about our at
least in that coke there's seven of them
yeah it's looking like King Kong is here
with a picture of Laura it was bad for
you none of it's good for you about RC
Royal chrome if you if you mix liquor in
it then it becomes healthy no little kid
I do love Springfield to Cola Lucky's
I've never had a soda I don't like
bubbles like I don't like champagne
either isn't that weird I'm live and
that's level your monophyly I don't like
that's fun yeah so you may know that yes
you don't like do you like your legs I
don't drink I never know it's not weird
growing up and then now I just I don't
like it my grandmother used to water
down or soda soda what's that a picture
he has multiple myeloma and chronic
kidney don't work right mikado beans how
do I follow that you said true story cuz
Jennifer opens from the broth I used to
date Jennifer Lopez for the Bronx that
was Mike's Jenny back then and then when
she started making it for the brothers
level here and started saying that I'm a
gold digger yeah sorry they work out
well too bad Queens our visitor Bronson
Lee 40 years but she's from back in the
day was that ask that big back there huh
was that ask that big inner smile it's
gotten bigger it's gotten bigger now did
you or did you have other so too right
you interviewed her right if you already
got Puff Daddy is who you invoke that
but good I never did you smell each
other's finger you don't have to that's
why you were called a gold digger I
would just think he'd be called like a
lucky
once you have the unibrow then huh want
to be the victim huh bro she had just
done muddy trail movie bro what you know
Jennifer you know JLo see this
eventually whatsoever I don't know that
guy she was just what you gonna see this
nobody bakes who lifts it to it goodness
she was working her way through the
Laugh Factory back then right showcase
at the Laugh Factory what she was there
right right and I remember she come in
after the show good oh my god you from
the Bronx to blah blah oh the set you
did you it was like home cookin you
brought back memories then maybe a week
later said you know you're talking to it
but anyway so then you know and then
just gold-diggin she was still a
waitress and every day I was a gold
digger we have that in common guys can
be gold diggers too as the poet yeah
yeah I would think there'd be a
different term because but that's very
me two of you - it's like be in the same
category as women people watch the
documentary or a tour for help out or
anything like that so we're waiting on a
couple of other so it's not the fest
like a big festival season right now we
actually got accepted to a like two
others that were we just decided not to
go to and I'm waiting on a few others to
find out and I'm waiting to get
distribution for it so I've been taking
a lot of meetings with people talking
about what the right thing to do is but
dr. drew is a producer on the film and
he's helping to figure out where it
should land but I think Netflix what
everybody says that's an obvious home
for it because yeah I hope they do I
really do - and so we're just trying to
figure it out and I like I already got
this like all these great things
happening around it so I can't see it
not ending up someplace great where
people can find it but yeah if it's
almost time summer in the meantime we
have a website called what's eating
Ralphie Maycomb or you can go on there
and look at the sizzle which is a one
minute
sample of the film and then sign up for
the email list we can keep you posted on
when it's coming out so it will be
hopefully in the next you know I don't
know I don't want to put it out there
how many months but hopefully soon it's
a very sweet story a very sad story and
yeah but you get to see all that you get
to see you guys in love and you know and
falling apart and that's pretty it's
really hard for me to watch it I cry
every time in the same place every time
no matter and I've watched it a couple
hundred times and it just it's a bummer
it really is I have to say I don't think
there's ever been a non biopic doc of
anyone that was famous in other words
showing their fall so when somebody dies
maybe you guys can correct me because
there might be something else out there
but we usually go back in and do a
biopic which is a film that picks up
footage from their life and shows their
story from other people talking heads
explaining what went on but this is the
first time I've ever seen a film that
actually shows the person making those
choices at the end of their life and
then and then taking the those steps
it's actual documentary it just blows my
mind those are the best documentaries
when you start out being one thing yeah
and unfortunately I mean life intervened
and changed this but life intervening or
something going hat wrong or or
something interesting happening during
the course of a documentary of changing
the documentary well yeah like exact
right there cuz I agree though watch it
which one is that why the years ago it
came out it's a guy who a guy who was
killed by his lover he was breaking it
off with her she killed him she's Irish
right I don't know the child yeah then
they write heat the filmmaker as a
friend of his who writes this movie this
documentary
as friends yeah when a decayed grows up
he couldn't get the video know a lot
about a father bit right the friends so
then she goes crazy cannon yes I don't
want to give every no no I you know my
soaking-wet change the course of its
[ __ ] shock
yeah you just why I don't really do my
son we watched it oh you like well he
had to do for a film school or he has a
film class in high school so that's a
watch that hard one to watch but it's
worth watching for sure yeah what's up
fool upcoming short man West Jordan Utah
West Jordan Lebanon West Jordan Utah
called Salt Lake City
so all the Samoans out there man can you
talk this weekend November 8 and 9 are
being wiseguys November 89 it that's
this week Modesto California November 18
of the Gallo Sentinel 15th that's the
50s to California November 5th team at
the gallows Center or less you're Latino
and Gallo center lui pickle Bakersfield
California number 16 at the Fox Theatre
Napa California who's at Napa November
22nd at Uptown Theater Seattle
Washington
November 23rd now this one man will need
a lot of help so far this shows November
24th so far sold five tickets ok Spokane
Washington man we need people to drive
but this promoter we sold nine ticket
people that please hose 2000 it holds
750 750 it's a huge place but nine is
ridiculous if that's a one flyer and the
bottom is say don't know I think you can
get more people if you pass that one
floor think you get more people than
what they got they got a check you out
Road San Antonio he destroyed for
sold-out show
yeah Pittsburgh Pennsylvania November 29
to the server first I'll be there on
Thanksgiving if anybody want to give me
a little blood such that people wait bro
oh and they know how they know your
flight plan hadn't just following you
and your logo so tell people be waiting
at the end or wheel and I who told them
Roger Paul just kind of hang out at the
airport and that's right let's start
let's start rolling now where will we go
feature philippe record for most
appearances and they line appears his
bro yeah the most important on this ride
oh wow bro and we had a beer ever did
the show bro earthquake then the guy ed
Alonso with a weird bird ken Jeong dr.
cadra for mm-hmm you know really really
really shine
besides Gabriel you know like a little
kid like didn't know who he was but they
were like I'm eight five years old
George Lopez bro he I don't know how he
was so funny brother I was like shocked
now like the Kabir's were bombings of
the time bro right where Jordan up it
was killing it
like I remember that Joe he said but I
was a little kid out my mom I wanna go
to Chuck E Cheese my mind my dad said we
want to see a rat yeah and she just
worth your rat whatever chunk of cheese
unless she blew the refrigerator was
full so how long did it take to fill
more than 10 years now well I mean
there's footage that was it was back 20
years ago but the thing itself the
actual course shooting was about nine
months and then a cat went back out and
visited Ralph's cat Reinhardt on the
road one more
and that was for something separate but
also she picked up more footage for the
film those twins they mentioned there
was no graves - what was that about they
were they were deep on that leg and they
like I don't want to like I don't know
what's going on but I I just talked to
somebody send it to me and I said bro
why are these guys pretending they're
crying what did you see did you see the
footage of another part about that they
there was no see they have a gravestone
or well Julius you saw bro no ok so
that's when they went on so I took me
awhile to figure out what it was even
going on from my end no they said that
when they went over there and there was
no he said what do you call them with my
passed away they put your name on the
ground a headstone stone grave stood
it's a [ __ ] graveyard ec yeah there
wasn't a headstone Mike they were
talking about it like the fact that
anybody can believe you go like I don't
know man I've made up it's totally made
up but they did ok it's so the story is
or there's a lot of they went on Joey's
podcast and they talked a lot of [ __ ]
about buying a headstone I think they
can they also really hurt Ralphie's
mother's feelings talking about how the
grave was not a phase mom's in this Oh
in the film yeah she does you know so
when when Ralphie passed she has a
family plot and she wanted Ralphie there
she wants to be with her son in that
Cemetery which is really [ __ ] sad
Ralphie buried by the way in Arkansas
when Ralphie died Ralphie didn't leave
there was no money I don't know if we
talked about that last time there was
like two hundred and eighty dollars in
his bank account so we got we managed
we're doing fine we were Swiss bank oh
yeah right well that's just it I found
so no I'm pretty sure that there was
money that went missing I know for a
fact money went missing because I had to
go to court and and and his business
managers got in trouble for taking money
out of the account and we had probate
which means some of the people at the
end of his life sued his children for
the last little bits of their money you
know the club owner in West Palm Dorfman
the the big guy there's too
there's the little brother and then the
big brother yeah Andrew and Brian Andrew
actually was in the film did you see him
in the film is sing at the table he
doesn't him off very well but he sued me
at the end of and so all these people
were in Rafi's life and the twins were
in his life at the end and when Rafi
died he went to Arkansas to his ashes
mother wanted to buy his headstone
mother gave money to one of Ralphie's
relatives and a lot of money like $1,700
and she's on fixed income but she was
insistent that she wanted to do this for
Rafi and the headstone didn't
materialize the person that the relative
of Ralphie's you always want to look at
everyone's picture right like look at
all sides it's [ __ ] up that this
happened but this particular person has
his own problems he's not a healthy man
so he needed the money I don't know what
happened I think his intentions were to
always get the headstone didn't happen I
was in contact with him all year I would
call him and be like is the headstone
coming and he said yeah yeah yeah it's
coming it's coming well it never came so
I started it I bought on my headstone
and then all of a sudden like I I have
it all like anyone can I can pull record
it's like I bought a headstone it's
coming and then all of a sudden I hear
from people and being nasty to me online
yeah like [ __ ] you didn't buy my
headstone you're a [ __ ]
this I'd be a horrible messages yeah
yeah well I like the word [ __ ] so I can
own it but people are writing me these
messages and I'm like what's going on
and then I look online and I get to see
this 10-minute snippet where they talk
about how how they bought him a
headstone and they were smoking weed on
the grave and nobody was going to buy it
and how I'm this terrible person and I'm
just devastated so I call the the
cemetery I'm trying to figure out what's
going on and it turns out they did they
put a headstone there so I have my
headstone coming and I'm like well what
do we do with mine and I got permission
I call him then Rob he's got two
headstones he went back for seconds
that's funny my dad had it took like
almost two years to get his headstone
common to take a while together
make it right there bro Geek Squad
there's no time frame to these things
right but also it's it's illegal you
can't go I can't just go put a headstone
on somebody's grave like I didn't mean
to look at you that was [ __ ] up that
so anyways but the crazy thing is is
that there if you listen to the podcast
and you listen to them because I know
they're talking about how they were
Ralphie was such good friends with them
and this on the other and all the things
that Ralphie did for them
Ralphie gave them a barbecue Ralphie
bought Joey a crib I was like putting
the barbecue girl on the back of there
no no not there it's like when if you
guys go out to dinner Felipe takes the
check you both bought dinner it's like
so and and with Joey I also gave him all
of my daughter's baby clothes like we
gave them so much and they're sitting
there just talking [ __ ] about Olli and
then I started thinking like what did
y'all ever do for him
boy you're talking about all the things
he did for you
and so I'm just like you know what
they're using this probably here's the
other part I like to look at things from
their perspective they probably believe
they did something nice for him so the
again though they weren't nice to me
which isn't nice to my children and they
ran a bunch of benefit shows after
Ralphie died make money doing benefit
shows and the benefit wasn't for the
estate so if they did put money into a
tombstone it wasn't their own money they
raised money using his name
so that's shady all in itself so this
the truth always comes to light like I
feel that way I have the opportunity to
have a voice and tell the truth so
anybody out there though the crazy thing
is is how could anybody hear that story
and give it any credit I mean you know
like Joey's not the healthiest man like
he's got a criminal background like this
is a man that that showed me his penis
20 years ago so this is like there's
more to this history
look at her clothes keep multiple times
human look at the human human egg rolls
as well what really yeah I'm sure he
showed it for many people like I am
sorry finally I have not seen the Cuban
I know Joe Diaz he has a Python though
if you're good if you're gonna do this
[ __ ] you better have a clean background
like if you're gonna talk [ __ ] just know
like you are not okay like right now you
don't that's a pretty big thing right
for a comedian to like make you
I sure he did it a couple of times I
would turn around and look at the wall
because I feel like that's not a sexual
play that's a power play right when a
dude just wants you to look you look at
it and just and to intimidate you yeah
you don't get it I never did I never
showed anybody but if I was to show you
my penis it would be a power play okay
I start shows about peanut and then put
my zipper down and see it the more I
pass out bro so the Cuban a girl yeah
that's what it was
well thanks opened up some [ __ ] Felipe
no your point of view to open up a file
yeah you know what promoting the
documentary to well you know the
documentary is gonna speak for itself
and there's always if somebody else to
hate and they can have talked about
Montreal no they biting and [ __ ] like to
put it out there why not you let see
that might be a good place that's a
great shot to show it and they're like I
know that his Netflix ghost Allah
a lot of his Canadian fans would love to
see it yeah sure and they don't care
about what we're talking about all they
care about the legacy they want to see
Ralphie the one of the don't care who
don't know or they want to see Ralphie
me know all the backstory is just
fascinating I've got so many fascinating
stories but the truth is is that Ralphie
left a legacy behind and it's my job so
I am an executor extreme in any word for
an executor it's my job to maintain his
legacy and I take that for serious I
mean I helped him build his career I was
there for him I loved my husband
and so you show me that rigging for the
Laugh Factory we're having a barbecue
the footage of that of him proposing no
when you had the engagement party at the
Laugh Factory I was there you know
there's a little bit of footage from
that still have that really used there
was the ring was pretty I stopped Shamus
thought I swear man he act like it was
his you know man during the during uh
though when they were together
Rafi me and Lana edenia the Laugh
Factory you know what it felt like now
and for like Pam and Jan Perry Jim and
my and I'm Jamie was my Jay Masada was
Michael Scott bro just trying to squeeze
the air bro these are mine they're my
kids and I thought when they left he was
all hurt I love you know what Jesus guys
that he was always good to us and I
always I've seen him periodically
throughout the years I you know I just I
don't have anything bad to say like you
Jamie was always really sweet um but I
wish I could get on stage there again
because when Ralph left the Laugh
Factory would kind of yeah was he one of
the comics that Jamie sued no like he
didn't try to manage him really on sham
but Jamie never sued on it was weird
because tried to sue people who like
stopped wanting him to manage them I had
a conversation with Jamie years later
after after Rafi had left me and
everything not that long ago a couple of
years ago and he mentioned to me
something about that there was an unpaid
bill and I
said I had no idea like I never saw any
bill so I don't know like I'm commission
I don't know probably and it's quite
possible but I just I never saw much but
but Jamie was good workers but like a
lot of people made their careers just by
being on that stage it's such a great
stage that's the best only thing I miss
is getting on that stage I believe I'll
get back up I've been up on there maybe
once or twice and they they parted ways
it sucks when one person's baggage
floats downstream and you're stuck in it
too you know but I was married to a man
I loved him and I mean you know when
things went south between them it it
myself between everyone right so so what
you doing right now besides the movies
tutorial yeah I'm gonna be in Kentucky
Ohio and then Tennessee next week bunch
of little shows sleepy I'm not big timer
like you but I'm doing all these little
shoes still I try and get out once a
month and do my hour so I keep my our
fresh because I'm ready to record it
this would be my second 1 hour and then
I just get up whenever I have time but
the movies really time-consuming and I'm
single mom so that's thank you going at
that show covering another big show
right and we're doing two shows we're
doing which they do that's English when
a Spanish or somewhere right right yeah
yeah we're doing that November 20th with
Martine Moreno yeah and we're doing a
beaver those jokes November 12 with the
Isaac Paco Martinez and tonight at the
comedy palace if you guys are listening
live I wanna give a shout out to that
dude that snuck in all the way to the
back of the [ __ ] stage at the
Humphrey by the pay man glasses and an
Asian guy and he for saying gay bro or
they were gay bro yeah bro I was
performing on stage killing it and I
look to the side and I thought back in
those days bro and when I got off he was
the first guy through a photo with and
then I remember him I started my
Instagram story bro this fools drove two
hours with his homies we gotta take it
and made it all the way
the back yeah he just looked like he was
ready to go strike something off that
stage after you were done he was just
like waiting you know and his hoodie and
I was like I think he works he must work
for them or something even though
playbook broadly my friend almost
techniques he's gotta give it he got it
though EMM r27 and did he pay for it
they get her just take it but he made it
always the back figured out how to get
back I used to do that I used to sneak
into concerts all the time and then
figure out how did you know what did you
sneak in what was your biggest cost you
snuck into it um solo this isn't a
concert but land this isn't gonna go
over it it's gonna sound weird when I
say it but I actually snuck into the
Republican National Convention which
sounds weird cuz I wasn't doing it to be
a Republican or anything like that
wasn't political by Rama tog refer back
then I when I was 19 I interned at The
Associated Press so I used to do photo
journalism and I used to sneak into
everything and it's amazing with a
camera and a you took a badge and turn
it backwards you can sneak into so many
things back then so I used to I mean
everything I'd sneak backstage at like
big festival concerts I've met Dave
Matthews backstage my bronies not get to
Pat to EWTN's locker room right yeah
yeah because I want to shoot the games
and so I would go into like where the it
was in Houston so I go back in the
locker the Rockets and then look at the
ground and penis everywhere on the
ground
a bag of Jamaican beef patties mystical
there you go that's a good memory huh
your Nick file why we have to go there
or Yankee or Mets
I like Jackie's thanks ex used to be my
team your big team onager big Knick fan
huh
I gave up on the next one I wouldn't let
Patrick Ewing go depressing huh hey bro
you know I'm being from New York do you
know a lot of the Bobbito a bit he's a
DJ or a radio DJ guy for a Rican Babbitt
oh he's in an NBA jam game Eric for a
condition score Bobby Bobby
from the Bronx picked up on the Browse
beat though you thought about it you
probably think about that we will just
write a column a truth why yeah bro you
remember what to close
yeah man bro
Mike Robles pick me Gabriel
we're like two days off in a little
brother we did open a liver and it takes
us to kunia Coney Island bro and I had a
[ __ ] love you gotta get both flavors
mustachio select a banana pistachio ice
cream bro it was [ __ ] delicious you
remember the ice cream delicious
pistachio one side and banana and the
other side and then we were shooting
those [ __ ] guns right and my goodness
shoes [ __ ] and he got beat by a solid or
a guy he's put a gorilla we cheated you
remember he was shot the same same
Claire remember we shot the same cloud
blow to win that prize with the prize so
we were to get okay five people we gay
bro and Mike shut the same cloud so that
[ __ ] blew up before everybody with you
what we're doing them did he plan it and
we do it with a hop in liquid and I
would avoid selling wearing a kidnap
Mike Robles and take up to the [ __ ]
right and there my crew is I gotta go
good we're gonna go bowling
look we're bowling at their [ __ ] it's
whenever I were bowling alleys at Port
Authority yeah boo to go bowling a
Hollywood lanes right where they shot
The Big Lebowski over there for 2:00 in
the morning is that way they had to
crack bowling yeah yeah that's it bro
closed down
you were I was still doing they were
still having bowling there yeah those
1999 like holes and cracks in it we go
yeah man they might have always go to
gutter could the ball of crack and what
is not fair
[Laughter]
it was cool back could you be boiling
there bro you see it's a rockstar
they're not a rockstar
come on yeah Vince Vaughn with our walk
come in there drilling a Christmas tree
good times he's coming to the bar I went
to where the best of the Hat we were
your comics man we're your comic you're
innocent you don't know what the future
holds and we were all hanging out at the
double in his man it was Halloween
Tuesday nights G Riley many men I Martin
Mourinho and me and a bunch of food we
walk to though I said I'm Monica
Hollywood a parade and we saw you and
Ralphie May dressed up like baby boy and
somebody you were wonder girl oh he was
supper man and I was snack or off yeah
yeah much I was costume but instead of
Superman was to build a slice of cake or
something no it was a big s for supper
man and yeah he he did a commercial for
something called shock comics in which
he played three different fat superhero
characters one where he's flying through
the sky and the people are looking up
and he comes crashing down and lands in
front of them and and that that's what
he wear that costume and then I just
like came up with snot girl cuz that's
funny
what's awful micro-level you were
shooting Kay local in West Coast a lot
of East comedian see how about us my
answer was I did comedy be contest they
could have rich Ramirez rest in peace
Iago and Joe Los Angeles on around here
which were very passed away yes
we whatever to the kid local papers I
get that page the web page everything
went so you know English okay so yeah 20
years they have all everything that's
well
giving you this stuff by the way I don't
mind promoting it it's crazy that it's
not going either it's not coming bring
it you know people ask me like why don't
you do it again and bring it back but to
me sometimes sometimes you can't mess
with something that has already been
successful like you don't touch it you
know I don't like that's already been I
know but like bad lieutenant tell it to
Ghostbusters and every other great movie
that Shaw's doing everything keeps
coming back to documentary Arthur you
can host it you know you're telling me
stories if I got whatever I would you go
behind the scenes but the bowling alley
bougie stuff really but Willie Barcena
didn't show up bro cuz that first look
you know all right man back in back in
the day we did the King local show in
Oxnard at the at some theater right oh I
never Rodrigo there baby
they're always there and I've been and
myself and I don't really other
comedians not important but much about
these shows they were all under the
guise of visions umbrella all right
everything we got a [ __ ] it's like when
you work with the show NBC and NBC's
watching you except we didn't have no
idea man I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm asking
everybody every stage half for weed we
had them behind the curtains but Willie
Barcena on one show okay he's a
headliner and let me tell you something
about
microbe is real cool at this point of
the game of the tour Willie Barcena and
they never even been a [ __ ] kill op
but first of all he wasn't even a kid
locals yet I don't think was out he was
Duke a local to a local comedy jam but
I'm he would not even show yet but he
was to headlining so this fool he was
lucky to be on the show
and anyway so [ __ ] it he leaves bad left
both it out we didn't know we were
looking for him
so what happened why did he leave Mike
what would the story oh you heard you
did something uh his homey huh you did
something to his homey Josh he looks
gangster women right here now I stick up
for my people all racial about what
against our racial bro no bro universe
took up here nobody dog but I'm gonna
stick up for him bro early v-day was it
a good of Riggs I remember he brought
beer right yeah you know God will be
show you you have to follow company
policies they get sued you know so yeah
no alcohol best age and I guess that's
what they don't want them drunk on you
mean on the tour or this part of the
tour the one walk all back basically
where they would never know didn't want
to sell it to also emerged the only one
I saw got a vision birch it's always you
know and Univision always got a video
they easy to sue so these great it was
for us back then and for the show our
show were promoting on television like
you'll see like the show finish if you
want to see more color cause they're
gonna be live and at the Arco Arena in
Sacramento at eight o'clock and ten
o'clock get your tickets right here and
let you know air on television who who
the [ __ ] else get that bone promotion or
nobody I wish I was there
do you holidays like Christmas 24-hour
marathon
24 hours straight and between each each
Tommy two hours that's where the story
is always said again well every every
every older Chawla was looking at me bro
after that it is telling the guy from a
local I saw you
okay look us when I was a kid people
still say this
I feel relevant man magic bro people saw
me when they were 8 or 16 that's right
and I care now that last comic standing
was [ __ ] ten years ago hasn't been
that long oh my god I was a Ralphie
Ralphie was dog how long's that been oh
gosh 15 years right or something like
that yeah he was you were worth it when
that happened what was Ralph amazed at
the house when he lost what that fence
when he lost after that no did you know
you were still with him right of course
yeah you're right we first went married
yeah yeah jeez no no we weren't even
gauged well what was that like a Jew was
like yeah I don't know Lisa was scared I
was scared because of your addiction
history I was scared you were gonna flip
out regardless of whether you won or
whether you lost I was worried because
as an addict you loved to celebrate and
celebration comes with alcohol and drugs
I celebrate losses and if you fail
damper year yes and I was afraid of who
to bring and I was even afraid to bring
his mom to the finale because like what
I didn't know if that was a trigger like
if he won or lost if he's is he gonna be
pissed that his mom is there is he gonna
be too old emotional and not know how to
handle you know all these questions in
my head he probably didn't expect to win
though that's the thing because so and
the crazy thing is we met a few years
ago the guy who edited so that basically
they're backstage is a guy with two
endings for the show and which button
they're gonna push in there waiting for
a phone call and it was a decision made
I I don't I I li I like that but I don't
think dad actually won because after
after the show
Ralphie just he had so many people
pouring out for him but I don't think
NBC and Ralphie never thought NBC would
want him at his size to be a
spokesperson for the network that was
much more presentable and you know they
dream all that's exactly very cat said
he said get your story right
and then like other comedians that I
talk to a lot of community went to show
before I got out just to be ready and
then Rafi told me he'd be honest and
then Dante too and everybody else
Gabriel - he said don't bring your phone
when after me and Barry talk later on
after the show years after he said that
that bad one because America felt bad
that he had to sleep under a desk edit
work that brain so you turned on the
heartstrings a solo they saw him as the
guy that's gonna make it light the
American Dream that and then when I won
that when I got a last comment standing
like a lot of the people are next to me
who were like kind of like bakery and
you know whatever but they forgot that
when you when I read everything I sign
you know and I stay right there you know
if we want to make you to be an [ __ ]
yeah
well the book you know that that first
season they had a different cast ready
to go and a lot of them wouldn't sign
wouldn't sign like huge and you signed a
tour right there too is regarded though
didn't even tell you how much you're
gonna make on the tour you just sign
away yeah but they knew they knew
there's just an outside observation here
but they knew they wanted an Asian and
actually they originally cast kim jong
ken wouldn't sign the document and
Alonzo Bodden they had him on there
butch Bradley was gonna be and then they
replaced them with other people that
looked like them but were just not as
much right yeah and Ralphie had Ralphie
not completely and totally destroyed
throughout the whole thing I believe
wholeheartedly that jay mohr fought to
keep Ralphie on that show that Jane knew
he what he had in Ralphie and but I
don't think that and Ralphie never
believed that NBC wanted him in the show
but they just couldn't get rid of him he
was such a powerhouse I mean if they'd
have not taken him out of the room then
they they wouldn't have continued on
like the audience would have been pissed
and actually when I did an audition a
few years later for Last Comic Standing
and I did it in Phoenix and I had a
killer set in Phoenix and they took me
out of Phoenix but dropped me before the
next round so they know not to they know
what to do in the
now but what not to do on camera I don't
know if that's true but that was for me
but I thought what happened I didn't I
won in the room didn't get to go to the
second round
yeah last time i standing once you make
it through like top ten
everybody tapes are losing video before
you win before you lose and I win him
because he could you lose we talk to you
make the [ __ ] away from me man I already
have it yeah so it's funny man went out
when my distant father was taping his uh
his losing video he said you dropped the
ball America but that guy was winning or
should've won
yeah then when they asked me who was
your fear is who did you scare you know
who thing's gonna beat you I can't say
my d'stefano but then they would not air
that on TV you can mic to get along
together too and then I'm at or ahead of
the team was talking about what the head
of his time you know and they were
laughing all that stuff will destroy now
just as well back there but yeah I don't
think that really big I would to take a
break or follow him because he was
getting a thing ovation ah follow that
[ __ ] following the girl follow that
that's funny I'm following the guy who
couldn't follow that so I'm gonna do
alright
did you know made that the funnel passed
away passed away right after the last
day stop smoking yeah I think it I think
it I think something shocked his system
there he had a heart attack he had been
yeah we were before we were waiting on
top of the mountain in Denver at a place
car even knowing what it's called right
now Kevin yeah Vail
Vail Colorado we're way up there and my
sister partner had an oxygen tank
breather the whole time we're out there
so he took it off it was just a stage
and then we saw him again in Kentucky
his he was red-faced but your sweater
yeah what's up fool tell us again Lana
where can people find or help out uh you
know financial no I just want to do a
shout out to you guys because we did the
the IndieGoGo campaign was for the for
okay well thank you you you love you
know you really did love Ralphie and the
kids and I know that they're awesome
they're are so awesome but these are the
Queen right remembers you being a
princess but but you guys actually did
help because we did the indiegogo for
the second so out of the same hard
drives that you see the documentary is
also a lot of found footage of Ralphie
and so there's another secondary
one-hour special of never-before-seen
footage and that's where you guys
chipped in so at this point is just if
people want to get online and like post
it can't wait to see it and stuff like
that but I mean we're in a good good
but they can go what's eating Ralphie
may calm yeah and you can and put in
their email address and get on their
email and get update so you can go on
social media I'm updating on my social
media too so that's just lah and I
always say there's an HMO know there was
backwards that spells annual but just
Lana Turner and then you can find out
more from that too and and we're still
keeping Ralphie's social media active so
you can see everything on there and and
there's a lot of stuff that but now if
you left a lot of stuff behind so it's
it's amazing how how much we're still
able to reappropriation and share so
much I mean there are so much footage
I'm just shocked I started to make me
feel like I'm not keeping enough footage
morbid right no I'm just saying like in
general like there's so much it was
almost on my heart poorest site to
capture all this stuff I mean it's not
just your footage it's the documentary
documentarians footage as well but it's
there's a lot of personal there's a lot
of video of us early on because we did
shoot those to reality well one was a
so this is a great story I moved to LA
got my first audition two months into LA
and got a pilot on Showtime which was a
documentary shot by the guys who surely
knows Sherman Oaks taxicab confession no
is that what you mean
no cause Sherman Rose at that maybe one
s oh no it never got picked up no it
didn't get picked up but I but literally
like I had that livery it was called the
Boulevard and it was about the point the
the the premise of the show was they
would take I don't know however many
people was seven or whatever people who
live work or play on the Sunset Strip
and follow them through their journey
and I went in auditioned and I got
chosen so I was in a Showtime pilot and
they did some footage of Ralphie and I
together because obviously visually we
were pretty impressive and you saw some
of that footage I mean their size
difference was notable and and so we had
that footage and then we had the vh1
which was an actual reality pilot we had
some of that footage and then we just
had like video that we took of ourselves
and from our different one-hour specials
we just a lot of stuff that's done back
to 20 years ago and yeah there's one
there's one clip when you guys were
talking about you were talking about how
NBC he didn't think NBC would want him
the way he looked
yes it's the winner and a spokesperson
for NBC and all that and there is a clip
of him saying a joke onstage about how
he auditioned and he got four four
callbacks and finally went for the
fourth callback and they said that he
was too fat he needed to lose weight to
play a fat guy yeah that he was way
every mean that's I'm assuming that's
true because it sounds so true like what
Hollywood what agents say and say crazy
things so at the end of his life so his
manager was Judy Brown at levity but he
also had Andrew Dorfman who was claiming
to be his manager so that's all very
convoluted but judy was my trouble Roger
pop yeah it's confusing I don't know
this one
what is it love like roebling's about
your paw Roger part I like claiming to
be Mike Robles agent manager producer
executive it's crazy landlord
yeah like the exact look the
the guy was originally his life coach
Wow and then he became as but I don't
even know this Scout it was crazy that
part of it was crazy but Judy was his
manager at the end of his life and Judy
used to put the Aspen Comedy Festival
you remember that and that was the big
festival so I was there in her forth and
be Aspen was what Montreal is now I
think it was like the big festival back
in the day and I was there the life I
drew Ralphie you did one of those
showcases where he got the standing oh
you know he was a beast blew up the room
got off stage arrogant as hell and
walked up to Judy and was like so do I
need to buy my ticket for Aspen and she
literally looked at him I was there she
cuz you're not going to Aspen and ruffly
was like I thought what like at first he
thought she was joking and if he goes
she goes you're too fat nobody will ever
put you on TV and obviously he was like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] like he was mad but then
fast forward 15 years later she actually
became as manager so that's how crazy
this business is that somebody can tell
you you're never gonna be on TV and then
represent you at the end of your life
like that's just that's our business
people will tell you know every step of
the way and just keep working at some
point they see what an impact you can't
stop an audience who wants to love
somebody and and Ralphie proved that
that but I mean I Ralphy really really
had to prove himself and even in I mean
he had a lot of good people though in
his life like keep him continually to
give Jay more credit for Ralphie's
career Jay believed in Ralphie like
nobody else and Jay and Ralphie gave you
credit for his career though several
times in the documentary well I helped
him a lot I mean and I I will take
credit for that and people might think
that's not cool but it's true I was with
Ralphie for almost 20 years and I mean
was with him seven years before I bought
the ticket for him to get a lost comic
and you know I helped him a lot and I
like also UK because you were holding
the family together and taking care of
the kids and everything that helps him
be free to have his career out there you
know what I mean like that's a huge one
understated fact right there you know
what it's true talk a lot of women yeah
and a lot of men are free to pursue
their careers because the woman is
that's why divorce is so incredibly
[ __ ] and that's why I like when you
when you
look at this somebody that you support
their career for so many years and then
now all of a sudden you're like okay now
I really need my career I've been busy
raising kids and like helping you tie
your shoes how am I supposed to get to
where I need to be now to support myself
and that's a whole other journey but um
but I I love stand-up I didn't it's
funny because after all that happened
I'm like how am I supposed to earn a
living now cuz I I've worked all these
years but I didn't work on building a
brand or anything so how do I'm like I
don't have any skill set all I can do is
write a great dick joke like where do I
go now so I just I just stay the course
because I don't know and I love comedy I
don't know how to do anything else so
here we go so I'm flying to Columbus
Ohio yeah so where are you gonna be we
gonna wrap up yeah
let me just go on my website there's no
performing um yeah yeah Columbus Ohio I
think Kentucky at the Clarksville
Tennessee in actually Nashville
Tennessee in the next week yeah what's
up fool and your fundraiser show is so
many people that want might want to
contribute and they do have a like a
place where people have a go fo B page
what's the goal for me beach golf a
bleep page that would help you know was
it go probably pay medical bills and
stuff huh what's the call to go it's
just my day bike Robles just what for my
face I think there's about twelve
microbus but look for this face I'll go
for it you know whenever we can donate
as always appreciate it you know my
problems G you go to my facebook it's on
there what's up fool agree go give me
some bobby bites
it's a Jordan Lopez Lopez I won't be
there tomorrow but have a good show bro
he'll be there hey keep that little
stash of coke there
what's up fool bring a two-liter take
you very much Lana - yeah thank you
Micro blue from get local Zack you Lisa
as far as I thank you very much